مقطع فيديو تابع لوزارة الدفاع الروسية من
الحرب في أوكرانيا يظهر أن قوات موسكو
في طريقها تتقدم على الأرض وهي تغذي قوات
كييف ،
لكن الواقع على الأقل في بعض الحالات
يبدو مختلفًا ، حيث يقول هؤلاء الجنود إنهم
حُشدوا من إيركوتسك في سيبيريا
وهم يرفضون القتال
بسبب  الوضع الحالي
نجد أنفسنا في وضع يائس
لأن القادة لا يهتمون
بحياتنا كما يقول في وقت لاحق ويضيف أننا نطلب
المساعدة ليس لدينا مكان آخر لقلب
الفيديو حيث
يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم قضوا على
القوات الروسية  في محاولة للاعتداء على فولادور في
شرق أوكرانيا وبعد خلاف عام
بين إفغيني بريغوسيون من
شركة واغنر العسكرية الخاصة ووزارة
الدفاع الروسية بشأن إمدادات الذخيرة
لمرتزقة فاغنر حول باكمود ،
يقول تقدم الآبار إن المشكلة قد تم
حلها ، وقد أخذ انتقادًا آخر في
وزارة الدفاع
جاء عدد كبير من الجنود السابقين الذين أصبحوا الآن جزءًا من فاجنر إلى هنا لأنهم
كانوا يبحثون عن المزيد من
الحرية الإبداعية لأن الجميع يفهم أن
الجيش لا يمكّن دائمًا من ذلك
عندما سألنا بيرجوسيان عما إذا كانت العلاقات
مع وزارة الدفاع قد تمت
استعادتها ، فإن الإجابة السريعة أيها
الرجال  أنتم جواسيس أعداء سي إن إن لديكم
ضمير حول كيف أن
القضايا العسكرية لسكوت معك
كتب على قناته على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فاجنر تقول إنها كسبت
أرضًا حول محمود في نهاية هذا الأسبوع ،
نشرت وسائل الإعلام الروسية الحكومية هذه
اللقطات التي التقطتها طائرة بدون طيار للدمار التام هناك
وادعى الأوكرانيون  خسائر فاجنر
هائلة ، أخبرني مستشار بوتين السابق سيرجي
ماركوف أنه لا يعتقد أن
بريغوشين يستخدم قواته كعلف للمدافع
لأنه يمتلكها لديهم
مجموعة اقتحام ولكن وفقًا
لمعلوماتي ، فقد حاول الحفاظ على
حياتهم لأنها هذه حياتهم
ملكه  ورجل أعماله ، حياتهما
هي ملكه ، نعم ،
لكن في حين يصعب تحقيق تقدم
لجيشه ، لا يظهر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين أي علامات على التراجع
بدلاً من إعلان حرب أوكرانيا على
أنها صراع مع الغرب ،
فإن لديهم هدفًا واحدًا للانقسام.
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق والجزء الرئيسي منه
الاتحاد الروسي من أجل دفع
المخلفات ووضعها تحت
سيطرتهما المباشرة